go to any workshops or conferences to
explain to anybody but but it might be
important so so so I uh and and all I
did was put it into a book that was
published last year so so I some of you
know that I
I I've been working for uh 60 years now
on a series of books called The Art of
computer programming and
um
uh last year uh
uh I guess I got my first copy at the
end of October uh what was volume 4 B
which includes which is half about uh
sad solving
but the other half is what I want to
talk about now uh which is which was
kind of a surprise as as I was working
on it uh so so
um
uh
and that's uh
[Music]
back covering
um
is that covering problem uh
which which then would generalize so so
the exact covering problem is very it is
all in what and well known
um uh and we call this XC
um
for short and uh I see it you can see it
uh it has a matrix for example of zeros
and ones and to get an exact cover the
idea is you just want to choose a subset
of the rows so that the sum is 1 1 1 1.
so so I want to choose a row so that
every column is covered exactly one
oh now um
uh for example uh
if every row has exactly two ones in it
uh this is the problem of perfect
matching because we have uh you have a
graph and and we put a a one under U and
under V if if there's an edge between I
I uh u and v and so until we have a
perfect matching we have a set set of
the edges so that every vertex is in is
is uh matched right
um
and uh
if every row has three ones in it then
we have the uh the problem of three
matching I mean actually uh uh the
different the different versions uh I
mean also in in the perfect matching
problem you have bipartite matching and
and general graph matching uh and and
similarly for for three matching uh uh
you could say that uh you have a tripart
type graph and uh you have boys girls
and
or let's say
uh well anyway uh
okay
I I don't know any boys boys girls and
pets or something like that and those
triples that are allowing you perfectly
and you have a situation where every uh
every one girl has a pet okay so now uh
if there's if there's four ones in every
row uh
Sudoku is one example because because
you can you can express
problem in this way you have to get one
uh uh you have to cover every every cell
of the board you have to cover every row
uh you have to cover every column and
you have to cover every box
yeah and of course there's many other
exact coverage problems where you don't
have the same number of ones in every
row
um and uh
uh now uh
a huge number of commentary problems uh
uh uh you know I knew were were related
exactly then
then you can um
uh you you can uh extend it slightly and
say that's
that's some of the columns uh uh you
only want at most one
instead of exactly one
um so so uh
um
and and so I I called
primary if you've got to have exactly
one and secondary uh if it's at most one
and and they behave like slack variables
uh in in linear programming because uh
if you say it's the most one then I can
add a bunch more rows that that are
optional that just put I just add in the
ones what uh one retirement uh but it's
it's better to just
think think right offhand that secondary
our special category okay so so I
started with this and
a familiar example of the of the case
with secondary variables would be the
end Queens problem so so so so we have
uh like a like a chess board we have 64
rows and each row uh uh and the columns
I have a column for each row and I have
account for each diagonal going each way
until every Queen in this case again uh
you know there will be a it's a certain
row to a certain column and then it's in
two diagonals and the rule is that we
can't have two queens in the same
diagonal but we don't have to cover
every diagonal so that's an example of
this of this case where where you have
secondary variable okay now um
the big surprise like I got one uh okay
then let's go back uh
um
I I guess I started playing out wrong
with data structures for this about 1990
and I and I wrote uh
uh can I designed us a kind of a fun
thing what they call dancing links which
was which was a nice nice data structure
for doing exact cover problems
um and the uh uh I'm not going to talk
about the data structure but but
basically it was designed to be very
easy to to do backtracking and undo what
you were doing so so every time I made a
change to the data structure it was
really easy to unchanged to unchange it
later on I want to back it up and um so
so I had this algorithm and I solved a
lot of problems for fun uh including the
uh and queen's problem which was uh a
little bit interesting because
most people who had studied and queen's
problem they would only cover the rows
uh but uh I mean at every choice they
would say well where should I put the
queen in this room but but my method was
symmetrical between world and columns so
so I might decide where should I place
the queen in this column instead of
instead of always going by Road okay so
anyway
um uh I I uh you you can set up all kind
of uh pentominal problems and things
like this they're all uh they're all
special cases of of exact covering but
the surprise the surprise was that I uh
I didn't see it uh lots of other
problems that that used a generalization
which we took xcc uh which is uh exact
covering with colors
an optional you here
depending on
um okay now um
what does that mean uh so we have our uh
our Matrix we have the primary uh
you know we have secondary
um
and in the secondary uh if I have if I
have a one that just means uh uh okay
even having most one of these
but in the secondary I can also put
things like a
and B in in different you know
different colors and the rule is you're
allowed to have
uh
you're allowed to have two of the same
color but but you can't mix the color
so so uh
they have so so
in secondary row uh
uh most one color allowed
so you think of the ones I said Each one
has some other unique color that doesn't
appear anywhere else and that would be
another way of saying so that's the
that's the problem of exact covering
with color and and uh uh well the the
nice thing about it was that I only had
to add a few dozen lines of code to my
original program for the ordinary exact
coloring problem and I had a solver for
exact code covering with colors it just
turned out you know the the I had to
purify the colors but I didn't I didn't
remove uh Rose quite as well so so like
that was uh that was amusing but then uh
as I started working with it I started
to I started to realize that this was a
really powerful model and it was really
good at stating more and more problems
and and so
as years when I I thought of more more
and more cases were where I could
oh where this this thing xcc problems uh
uh were applicable and and uh also I I
when I was looking at more and more
examples I I changed I changed the name
so instead of instead of rows and
columns uh I I think of it I I now say
options and items and so oh
options the the problem is is to choose
options
um and each item each primary item has
to be covered
uh so uh and and that that
change in terminology uh is that is
actually uh you usually when you think
of a of a problem that somebody gives
you to solve we say what what are the
options that I have to uh to choose
between it turned out to be that those
words uh sort of I don't even suggest
about so so make a long story short I
um I I found uh uh
many hundred models that that are in
value 4B for people to look at that
covering
all kind of common thoughts and and
pretty soon I came to like to realize
that every CSV is also a special case of
the on this on this model so so
for example you know in the CSP you have
uh you you have uh uh variables and and
domains and and so on so so the the idea
is each each uh
well let's say that one of the items is
is the name of a relation
and so then you have you list all the
options for the relation
and the values of the variables could be
the color of of that item so the
variables could be secondary items and
and their colors are the values of those
variables and then the uh the primary
items to cover are the relations and
says yeah you have to choose which
option which which uh Tuple of the
relation uh uh is the thing but you
cover every relation uh uh once so it
turns out uh you you can also model the
uh instead of giving all the tuples you
can also say that the non-tuples of a
binary relation and use secondary items
to block those out so so here I have I
cut to an hour in a situation where if I
have a problem to solve I've got a uh I
I I've got three choices
uh I can use the sets over like use the
CSP server I can use an xcc solver or I
can you know use
my favorite programming language you
write my own custom backtrack of course
but uh uh but but they all uh all three
of them are actually viable and after 20
years uh I've got you know a lot of very
mature
existing solvers there and and uh yeah
who knows uh this might turn I I think
that the model for actually extreme
from a user's point of view of setting
up a new problem uh it is often easiest
in the xcc sense
easier than making up a satin model or
another so so so I you know I work on
problems I I translate from One models I
I track the sad solver which comes
veterans and and uh uh last year I wrote
uh a new xcc climber which uh uh which
is one of the most subtle programs I
ever wrote and I still haven't found any
bugs but I keep I keep trying
um and uh and so I thought I'd I'd like
to advertise it today so that more
people could I could could experiment
and see if there is really something
here it's conceivable that 50 years from
now people you know who will have these
three bottles and they won't remember
which which came first historically when
you have three things
[Music]
not realizing how versatile it was going
to be
there's also a further model uh which is
MCC
which is uh multiple uh
uh-huh multiple
with multiplicity covering with
multiplicities and colors and this means
that instead of for the primary items
you don't say it has to be exactly one
but you give a range you can say the
range it can be between three and five
or zero and six or whatever so if you
get an interval for every uh for every
primary item as to as to how many
options it should have in the final
solution
uh now uh I I think Chuck Connors has
worked it out so that week that time uh
if you if you want uh to um to get some
examples uh he's going to cover a
slideshow running you know every five
seconds it change to another page of
this uh of this book and if you wanna
if you uh so you have two options you
can either buy volume 4B or you can try
to use the version that was that was
online a year ago which I don't maintain
but but it's available uh it's available
online and and the URL is
is you get to my own page
and then say fasc
I've seen
dot ps.tz for postgroup uh Jesus
and and so that that's what he did a few
minutes ago and and got this far like
you're looking at
that here
and if if you change uh
if it if you change 5c
to 7A
you you get the the current draft of
what I'm working on now for applying for
C which is about uh constraints
satisfaction
and uh best thing I wanted to say is
that uh
working with the CSP I learned new data
structures for representing domains and
uh and and Christine
showed me how to use this so-called
sparse said data structures uh to uh to
do the same kind of things I was doing
with dancing links and so I now with
Christine's help we have this new uh
this new xcc solver
and several others with different
heuristics uh that use uh that used the
sparse said data structure instead of
dancing and and uh
and like she gave a beautiful name to
this dancing cells so so we call it the
dancing cells uh NATO structure and and
with with some friends so we've been
running hundreds of examples of all
kinds and we're finding that dancing
cells is winning about two-thirds of the
time uh sometimes sometimes by a factor
of two or three but uh but but it's
consistently good uh but sometimes the
old dancing links is uh uh
is a winner and I haven't yet figured
out how to
to get my MCC solver uh uh onto sparse
said uh
but
should be possible okay question
question
[Applause]
does this it's over do uh backtracking
or look ahead
does your server do local look-aheads
the salver yeah so it uses uh forward
checking essentially uh
the main one to another adapter
I choose which primary item uh I should
try to cover next and I I took you know
maybe there's only one option left so
let's decide sports but but but nice
cases there's only two options you know
so I try the first one
um and uh well in branch on it now and
and you know like once I choose an
option I then I throw out all the uh all
the other options that clash with it
that means they've already been covered
uh in the primary column or it means
that they have the wrong color in the
secondary column
uh
and so then uh
it's time to cover something else I I
keep going this way and and then back
back up and and the beautiful thing
about the sparse that data structure is
that it's
it's very fast to back up
the nicest thing is actually I it can
stop in the middle
as soon as I find that something has
been wiped out it's easier for the
sparse set data structure to recognize
this that then for the doubly linked
data structure to do that
um so so uh
and my new uh
my new version that I did last year uh
does more than forward checking it
actually does full domain consistency
and and uh it was
so you what that means is that I I can
remove any option that no longer has uh
support
for for every option and every primary
item uh that there has to be a way to to
use that option
every every option every primary item
not not covered by that option I want to
make sure that
applying this option isn't going to wipe
out that other primary item so I have to
record a support for that and that's
that's it
a really tough problem when I found it a
a cute way to do it fast
so this covering problem we saw a bit in
logic minimization I it's it's you've
generalized that so there's a covering
Matrix for figuring out the prime
implicants of the function yes and
choosing the minimum Prime set of prime
implicants that covers all of the Min
terms yeah and here the uh the the the
rows
uh have a cost uh I mean I'm sorry the
columns have a cost in your case
yeah I think you attended 90 degrees so
I'm kind of a little confused yeah okay
and and one of the problems with it is
sometimes the uh one of the dimensions
of this Matrix is exponential
the number of Roads or number of columns
exponential or maybe both can be
exponential
and we've tried to encode this with set
to do implicit covering instead of
enumerating them exclusively so so every
every uh csb can be translated into xcc
in several ways into sat in several ways
and every sad problem can be translated
to CSP in several ways and xcc in some
ways
um the the the prime implicant type of
thing uh it introduced two issues that I
first of all it's not exact covering
you know
but but still you want to cover each one
so that would be an MCC problem movement
where the number is one to ten instead
of instead of exactly one
um uh but also you mentioned you know
having a cost function Associated so so
uh in in YMC I I show how to how to add
extra extension so they can get them in
cost uh exact cover with cut with colors
question
also there's an extension that that
finds that finds a zdd for all the
solutions it doesn't work for for the
arbitrary xcc problem but it works for
lots of them
and that means you've got a fast way to
account Solutions instead of enumerating
them one by one
okay well thank you let's try to get a
slideshow going for anybody who wants to
yes we're also going to attempt to do a
group photograph uh do we do we know
where
um no well
we're going
to go okay and we'll we will uh I think
Don again
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]